Portatevi ad un punto di quiete.
Allora abbiamo due cattive relazioni con il corpo.
Noi crediamo di possederlo e noi crediamo di essere il corpo.
Possession and identity.
So just contemplating the idea of possessing the body first.
Quindi prima contemplate questa idea del possedere il corpo.
Con le altre cose, se ci piacciono noi ci aggrappiamo ad esse, se invece non ci piacciono le buttiamo via.
E la maniera in cui espressiamo questo dislike nel corpo è un senso di disgusto.
Il modo in cui noi esprimiamo questo non amore per il corpo è un senso di disgusto.
Quindi il primo esercizio è quello di scorrere il corpo dalla metà del capo fino a giù alla punta dei piedi e di osservare ogni sua parte man mano che si scende.
E se arrivate a una parte del corpo che vi suscita un po' di disgusto, allora rimanete lì e realizzate il fatto che avete questo tipo di relazione con quella parte del corpo.
Questo è ovviamente molto simile al nostro esercizio di Vipassana.
Quindi questo è molto simile ai nostri esercizi di vipassana.
Ci sono delle parti che ovviamente ci portano a disgusto, che sono appunto gli intestini, tutta la parte dell'intestino.
Poi ovviamente ci sono tutti i fluidi, quindi il sangue, la linfa, il catarro, l'urina, tutte queste cose meravigliose.
parte della tua relazione con il corpo e come sappiamo le emozioni danno male al corpo non è bene per il corpo avere questa sorta di relazione
Quindi scorrete il corpo e quando trovate queste parti che vi provocano disgusto rimaneteci su per qualche minuto perché questo indica che tipo di relazione si ha con quella parte del corpo.
E sappiate che le emozioni hanno un effetto ovviamente sul corpo e avere una cattiva emozione in qualche modo influisce.
Quindi trovate una parte verso la quale avete questo senso di disgusto.
E avendo trovato quella parte, rimaneteci per un po'.
Quindi pensate a quella parte o come ai processi chimici o a un organo che ha una funzione.
E vedete se la vostra relazione cambia.
Poi ci sono quelle parti del corpo che amiamo o non amiamo.
Questo ha a che vedere con il nostro senso della bellezza.
È il suo opposto, la bruttezza.
Questa è una cosa che ci è culturalmente imposta.
Quindi ora, quali sono i vostri sentimenti verso il vostro corpo?
Allora quali sono i vostri sentimenti nei confronti del corpo?
Cosa dite a voi stessi?
È troppo grasso, troppo magro?
Guardate il vostro viso nello specchio.
Cosa vi state dicendo?
Le orecchie troppo grandi, il naso troppo lungo?
E di nuovo, immaginando il vostro corpo e il vostro viso, ditevi che questo è un organismo che ha una funzione, uno scopo, un lavoro da fare.
E che sta facendo del suo meglio.
E' la maniera in cui lo trattiamo, che spesso è messa in giro.
è il modo in cui lo trattiamo che a volte crea dei pasticci e poi viceversa ci sono delle parti del corpo a cui noi siamo attaccati per via del piacere che ci provocano
Quindi come sappiamo dalla nostra meditazione dove c'è un attaccamento al piacere c'è anche un potenziale di sofferenza.
Prendiamo i primi due sensi del vedere e del sentire, ascoltare.
Come vi sentireste se voi cominciaste a perdere il vostro udito, la vostra vista?
Noi sappiamo delle persone che hanno questo tipo di disabilità che non necessariamente toglie qualcosa, indebolisce la qualità della vita.
Ma senza dubbio c'è una certa quantità di sofferenza nel perdere questa abilità.
Quindi queste contemplazioni in qualche modo indeboliscono il nostro senso di possesso verso il corpo.
Andando più in profondità verso il senso di identità, verso il me,
Quindi possiamo ripetere le nostre contemplazioni della sera che servono proprio per sradicare questa ossessione che abbiamo per la salute, per la bellezza, per la vita stessa.
Quindi ripetiamo queste frasi accettando proprio il loro valore di verità.
Questo corpo è soggetto alla malattia.
Questo corpo ha in sé la natura di ammalarsi.
Questo corpo non è andato oltre la malattia.
Questo corpo è subito all'agire.
questo corpo è soggetto all'invecchiamento questo corpo non è andato oltre l'invecchiamento questo corpo è in questo momento in un processo di invecchiamento
questo corpo è soggetto alla morte questo corpo non è andato oltre la morte questo corpo morirà
Quindi queste contemplazioni minano il nostro senso di identità con il corpo.
Proprio come la metta, è bene praticarli un po' tutti i giorni.
Quindi ora dobbiamo considerare quanto il corpo è precioso.
Adesso dobbiamo considerare la preziosità del corpo.
Quindi il Buddha ha detto che questa è una rinascita preziosa.
E abbiamo quindi questo insieme di
gioia e dolore e abbiamo un modo per un'intelligenza per uscire da questa sofferenza la dukkha non potremmo essere qui senza un corpo è attraverso il corpo che noi arriviamo a conoscere tutto quello che abbiamo visto, che abbiamo sentito tutto, eccetera
è attraverso il corpo che possiamo creare delle relazioni ed è attraverso il corpo che noi facciamo delle opere buone per il mondo creiamo buon karma, sviluppiamo le nostre virtù
E in molti sistemi è proprio il respiro del corpo che noi usiamo per sviluppare i sette fattori per l'illuminazione.
Quindi adesso che abbiamo una buona relazione con il corpo la nostra benevolenza verso di esso sarà ancora più pura.
E prima di offrire Metta al mio corpo mi piace scusarmi con esso chiedere perdono adesso per tutte le cose tremende che gli ho fatto.
qualunque danno io abbia fatto a te attraverso i pensieri, la parola o le azioni attraverso l'avidità, l'odio o l'illusione, l'ignoranza volentieri o non volentieri
Volontariamente o involontariamente.
Mi dispiace perciò.
E mi impegno da questo giorno in poi a trattarti con rispetto e cura.
Adesso scegliete una frase che esprime per voi questa benevolenza verso il corpo.
Posso tu essere libero dalla malattia o dai disturbi?
Tu possa stare bene ed essere forte.
Quindi una di queste frasi va bene, fatela scaturire dal cuore e ripetetela.
Alcune persone nel fare questo visualizzano del calore, altri un colore.
Non ha importanza, è solo un modo per direzionare la nostra benevolenza verso il corpo.
Quindi prendiamo un po' di tempo per scorrere il corpo, dalla sommità del capo fino alla punta dei piedi, offrendo questa benevolenza a tutto il corpo.
Inizia con il cuore e la scapola, offri la tua benedizione lì.
Cominciate con la testa, insomma con i capelli e il cuoio capelluto e offrite lì le vostre benedizioni.
Versate la vostra benevolenza, la vostra gentilezza amorevole nel cervello.
benedite i vostri occhi le orecchie il naso e tutte le cavità nasali
La bocca con la sua lingua, i denti, la mascella.
Versate la gentilezza amorevole attraverso la vostra gola, la preziosa scatola della voce.
Tutta la testa è calda e energizzata.
Posa tu essere libera dai disturbi, dalla malattia.
Posa tu stare bene e essere forte.
Torniamo ora l'attenzione alla spina.
adesso poniamo la nostra attenzione sulla spina dorsale quindi offrite le vostre benedizioni cominciando dal collo e andando tutto giù lungo la spina dorsale giù per il collo lungo la schiena
Nella parte inferiore della schiena, nel fondo schiena.
Fin giù fino alla punta estrema.
La spina interna si sente calda e energizzata.
Tutta la colonna vertebrale si sente calda, energizzata.
Posso tu essere libera dai disturbi, dalle malattie.
Posso tu essere forte e sana.
Torniamo la nostra attenzione ora alla schiena sinistra.
adesso poniamo l'attenzione sulla spalla sinistra massaggiatela con la gentilezza amorevole poi andiamo giù fino al gomito
Giù verso il polso.
E dentro la mano, massaggiando la mano con la gentilezza amorevole calda.
Così tutto il braccio si sente caldo, energizzato.
Questo tuo essere libero dai disturbi, dalle malattie.
Questo tuo essere sano e forte.
Torniamo l'attenzione alla schiena destra.
Adesso poniamo l'attenzione sulla spalla destra.
Massaggiatela con la gentilezza amorevole.
Scendiamo fino al romito.
Giù verso il polso.
Poi nella mano, massaggiando la mano con la gentilezza amorevole calda.
così tutto il braccio si sente caldo e energizzato possa tu essere libero dai disturbi e dalla malattia possa tu essere sano e forte adesso mettiamo la nostra attenzione sulla zona del petto quindi qui puoi benedicare ogni organo individuale
qui potete benedire ogni organo ogni singolo organo pure potete sentirlo proprio come uno spazio unico e versare la vostra gentilezza amorevole uno spazio sentito offrite lì le vostre benedizioni
Tutta questa zona si sente calda, energizzata.
Posso tu essere libero dai disturbi, dalle malattie.
Posso tu essere sano e forte.
Passiamo alla zona del midriff, dove il stomaco e la testa sono.
Poi scendiamo nella zona di merito dove c'è lo stomaco e il fegato.
Di nuovo potete benedirlo organo per organo oppure sentirlo come uno spazio sentito.
In tutta questa zona si sente scaldata, energizzata.
Posso essere libera dai disturbi, dalle malattie.
Posso essere sana e forte.
Scendiamo nell'addome con tutta la sua varietà di sistemi.
Anche qui potete vederlo come potete benedire le singole parti oppure vederlo come uno spazio sentito e versare lì la vostra gentilezza amorevole.
Tutta questa zona si sente scaldata, energizzata.
Posso essere libera dai disturbi, dalle malattie.
Posso essere sana e energizzata.
Torniamo ora l'attenzione alla schiena sinistra.
adesso mettiamo la nostra attenzione sull'anca sinistra massaggiatela con la gentilezza amorevole scendiamo al ginocchio
Giù alla caviglia.
Poi dentro al piede, massaggiando il piede con la gentilezza amorevole calda.
Tutta la gamba si sente calda, energizzata, che tu possa essere libera dai disturbi delle malattie, che tu possa essere sana e forte.
Torniamo l'attenzione alla schiena destra.
adesso portiamo l'attenzione sull'anca destra massaggiandola con la gentilezza amorevole scegliamo giù verso il ginocchio
Giù verso la caviglia.
E dentro il piede, massaggiando il piede con una gentilezza amorevole, calda.
Così l'intera gamba si sente scaldata, energizzata.
Tu possa essere libera dagli disturbi, dalla malattia.
Tu possa essere sana e forte.
Quindi ora abbiamo offrito la nostra benedizione amorevole all'intero corpo.
Noi abbiamo offerto la nostra gentilezza amorevole a tutto il corpo.
Se c'è una parte che richiede un'attenzione speciale.
Quindi andateci adesso e stateci per qualche minuto offrendo la vostra gentilezza amorevole.
Adesso apriamoci a questa possibilità di ricevere aiuto di fuori di noi stessi.
Immaginate che vi entri da lì sopra un raggio di luce dorata
Va bene qualsiasi colore, quello che voi pensate che sia un colore di guarigione.
E mentre scende questo raggio forma una specie di cascata appena sopra la vostra testa.
mentre cade in questa palla la palla assume la qualità di un liquido e la palla comincia a ruotare delicatamente, lentamente
quindi lasciate che questa palla di liquido vibrante energizzato lasciate che tocchi appena il vostro capo può anche non essere un'immagine vivida può essere solo un'idea
quindi c'è questa luce che splenda all'interno della palla la palla che delicatamente ruota adesso lasciate che delicatamente scenda a spirale giù lungo la testa
e che trasformi tutto in questo liquido dorato caldo sentite la sua energia che entra nei vostri occhi, le orecchie, il naso, la bocca
e attraverso la gola sta ancora versando questa luce dorata dall'alto in questa palla che adesso sta ruotando intorno alla vostra testa
e trasforma tutto in questo liquido vibrante lasciate che questa palla si estenda al di sopra delle vostre spalle e fate in modo che cominci a scendere a spirale lungo il petto
sentendo quel liquido caldo e vibrante la schiena, la parte anteriore del vostro petto e dentro, molto profondo
La luce sta ancora entrando dall'alto attraverso la testa e la gola.
Entra in questa palla che sta delicatamente ruotando dentro il vostro petto.
Lascia continuare la sua descente nel midriff
Lasciate che continui la sua discesa nella parte mediana, trasforma tutto in questo caldo liquido vibrante.
e questa luce sta ancora entrando su dall'alto attraverso la testa, la gola nel petto e entra in questa palla che sta delicatamente ruotando in questa parte mediana
Lasciate che adesso continui a scendere profondamente nell'addome.
La spina dorsale, la parte anteriore, nelle braccia, nei gomiti.
ancora entrando dall'alto attraverso la testa, la gola, il petto nella parte centrale dentro questa palla che delicatamente ruota nell'addome e la lascia completare il suo viaggio attraverso il resto degli armi e le leghe
e lasciate che completi il suo viaggio attraverso le braccia e le gambe trasformando tutto in questo liquido caldo, vibrante e dorato
Adesso con l'ispirazione risucchiate questa energia attraverso la spina dorsale fin su alla testa.
Questa energia è la nostra stessa energia.
E con l'inbretto lasciatela unire con l'energia nuova dall'alto.
e con la espirazione lasciate che si unisca a questa energia che arriva dall'alto e lasciate che scenda lungo il corpo come una cascata
Se c'è una parte del corpo che richiede maggiore attenzione, non lasciate che penetri in quella parte come l'acqua penetra in una spugna.
Adesso possiamo condividere questa energia tra di noi.
Con l'ispirazione ricevete energia dal vostro compagno sulla sinistra e portate questa energia con l'energia dall'alto e la vostra energia nel vostro cuore.
Quindi attirate questa energia insieme alla vostra energia e all'energia che arriva dall'alto, portatelo nel vostro cuore.
E con la respirazione offritelo al vostro compagno di destra.
Se c'è una parte del corpo che richiede maggiore attenzione lasciate che attraversi quella parte.
Quindi adesso se c'è qualcuno che ha un particolare problema fisico, potrebbe venire a sedersi sul nostro posto magico, sedile magico, e noi lo colpiremo in qualche modo.
Direzioneremo l'energia lì.
Quindi dobbiamo direttare le nostre energie verso Luisa.
Quindi direzioniamo le nostre energie verso Luisa.
Quindi con la inspirazione noi attiriamo queste tre energie nel nostro cuore.
Quindi quella dall'alto, quella dal nostro vicino e all'interno di noi stessi.
E con l'ispirazione noi facciamo un'offerta, un augurio di buona salute a Luisa.
Tu possa essere libera dalle disturbi, dalle malattie.
Tu possa essere sano e forte.
Ma non c'è bisogno, penso, di tradurre questa parola.
Siamo liberi dalla malattia e dalla malattia.
Siamo liberi e forti.
facciamo le nostre benedizioni per Anna Caterina
Con l'ispirazione attiriamo queste tre energie nel nostro cuore.
Con l'espirazione auguriamo buona salute.
Buona salute.
May you be free of sickness and disease, may you be well and strong.
Ok.
Allo stesso modo facciamo i nostri buoni auspici a Isabella.
May you be free of sickness and disease, may you be well and strong May you be free of sickness and disease, may you be well and strong
May you be free of sickness and disease, may you be well and strong.
Anyone else?
adesso possiamo portare all'attenzione del gruppo qualsiasi persona che noi sappiamo che sta amare o sta morendo basta dire i loro nomi Peter Albert
Claudio.
Dina.
Alberto.
Maria.
Stefano.
Giulia.
For those who are sick just offering our blessings breathing in those three energies breathing it out towards them
Quindi per coloro che sono malati, offrendo loro la nostra energia, quindi inspirando, accumuliamo queste tre tipi di energia e ispirando la offriamo.
May you be free of sickness and disease may you be well and strong.
And to those who are dying
per coloro che stanno morendo che loro trovino il coraggio e l'equanimità per attraversare quell'esperienza e vederla come parte del loro processo di liberazione
e infine offriamo la nostra benevolenza a tutti gli esseri in tutte le direzioni possono tutti gli esseri essere liberati dalla sofferenza fisica possono essere liberati dalla sofferenza mentale
Sono liberati da tutta la loro sofferenza.
Che possano tutti gli esseri vivere appagati e con la gioia.
Possano tutti gli esseri vivere in pace e armonia.
Che tutti gli esseri possano provare la pace e la beatitudine del Nibbana.
Sādhu, sādhu, sādhu.